So, you know how you'll get really excited
about starting a new project?
Whether it's writing a book,
or making a song on guitar,
or completely reinventing yourself in the
space you're in?
But then as the days go by,
your enthusiasm fades..
and fades..
and fades..until it just shrivels up and
DIES and you completely forget about it.
The first, most important, and hardest
part of leveling up, is DECIDING to.
You have so much willpower.
We, as human beings, whenever we decide
we really want something,
we go after it, and we make it happen.
There's no such thing as
"I'm too busy for that."
It's just, "Mm, I don't think I want to
invest the time necessary to complete
that goal."
Which brings me, to the
two biggest hurdles standing between
you and what you want to accomplish:
Total time mismanagement
and not setting realistic goals.
We throw SO MUCH time away just doing
absolutely nothing.
And then we have these, these GRAND goals
and ideas and dreams
that seem so overwhelming, that we never
finish them, because we don't
start off small.
If you really want to get something done,
be honest with yourself.
So if you tell me,
"I'm gonna write for 2 hours today."
Are you REALLY gonna write for two hours?
Is that something that you are ACTUALLY
able to do?
No?
How about an hour? How about 30 minutes?
How about 15 minutes?
15 minutes of writing? I can do that.
Totally. Totally do-able.
So if you want to reach this fabled
"level 5," start managing your time
and setting goals that you KNOW that
you can complete.
I use an at-a-glance planner, it breaks
down the week PER HOUR,
it's AMAZING, highly recommend it,
and whenever I cross something off
of my list, I reward myself with a cookie.
Or chocolate. Something sweet.
Something delicious. That is--
That's all that's needed to get
something out of me. (chuckles)
So you know, start,
start leveling up, because you totally
can. It's just a matter of deciding to,
and then going from there.
Okay?
Good luck.
I'll see you next week.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara